- Doctor, when the CDC
Director, Robert Redfield,
says these new guidelines
are meant to facilitate
the opening of schools around the country,
not keep them closed.
Based on your reading
of these new guidelines,
do you think they accomplish that goal?
- Well Wolf, they sound
different from the guidelines
that were released before.
And I kept on thinking, what
is it that's so different?
And what's different is the tone,
because what I'm used
to seeing from the CDC
is leading with the science and the facts.
And these guidelines sound like
they're cherry picking data
to make a specific policy point.
And that's really concerning,
because what we need
from the CDC is not a
justification of why children
should be in school.
We all know that, we all want that.
But we want the CDC to lay out,
what are the criteria
that we need to meet?
For example, we need to test
positivity less than 5%,
a consistent, 14 day decline
in the number of cases.
Something like that.
And also, here's a
checklist of what schools
have to do in order for schools,
for them to reopen safely, in person.
That's not what the CDC
really has laid out.
And I really worry, if we can't trust
that what comes out from
them is based on science
and not politics, then who can we trust?
- Yeah, that's a real serious
potential problem out there.
Sal, you just had an excellent interview
with Dr. Anthony Fauci, yourself,
and you asked him about bringing teachers
and the students back to school.
Let me play this clip. Listen to this.
- When you talk about forcing teachers
to come back to school, you
better be careful about that,
and make sure you pay attention
to A, keeping them safe,
and key, keeping them healthy.
- Sal, I want you to elaborate
a little bit on that for us.
What are some of the best
practices that Dr. Fauci outlined?
- Yeah well, first of all,
just to completely agree
with what was just said.
What I think, we're talking
to school district leaders
around the country, and
what they're craving
is just very clear guidelines.
What is the per capita
incidence rate, and for each
of those levels, what is
the appropriate action?
And there's good groups, like
the Harvard Global Health
Initiative Institute, that have been
doing very clear guidelines.
And Dr. Fauci did seem to say
that those types of guidelines
are what folks could index on.
And the timing is super important,
'cause we're only four to six weeks away
from school starting, and school leaders
really even haven't had a chance to think
about how the instruction's
going to happen,
'cause they don't know how
it's going to be structured.
In terms of what we just
heard from the statement
about teachers, I did
ask him very directly,
should teachers be forced to go back?
And he seemed pretty
empathetic with the situation,
especially for older teachers,
teachers who might have some
other health circumstances,
that they shouldn't be
forced to go back to school.
We talked about social
distancing, but once again,
it would be valuable to
get very clear guidelines
of what's good and what is not.
And also, there's interesting ideas
of maybe leveraging outdoor classrooms.
There's a South Korean study talking
about over 10 years old,
versus under 10 years old.
What can we do with say, kindergarteners
or first graders, outdoors?
Some type of clear
guidance along those lines
would be super valuable.
- You're absolutely right.
Dr. Wen, even as the white house pushes
a complete return to schools, a key member
of the corona virus task
force, Dr. Deborah Birx,
is cautioning that it's unclear
how rapidly young children,
even under the age of 10,
can transmit the virus.
So we know this one study
that Sal was referring to,
in South Korea, said that children over 10
transmit the virus as
quickly and as thoroughly
as adults do.
What additional evidence
would you like to see
on that critically important front?
- Yeah, so that particular
study from South Korea,
it actually only looked
at symptomatic people.
So we don't know about
asymptomatic transmission,
and since 40%, or even more,
of cases are transmitted
by people without symptoms,
we really don't know
whether asymptomatic
children, young children,
can transmit just as
much as older people too.
I think also, when you look at
the studies done of children,
they have all been in countries
where the transmission
rate is really low, and
so we really have no idea
what it's going to look like in the US,
if kids are going back in places
where there are active surges.
And I'm afraid that this looks like
an uncontrolled environment,
where our children,
and our teachers, and their
families, are guinea pigs.
- You know Sal, in your interview,
Dr. Fauci also spoke about
the potential downsides
of relying on face shields in schools,
rather than requiring students
and teachers to wear masks.
I wanna play this clip, watch this.
- My staff just brought this in. (laughs)
- There you go.
- This was a great-
- That's exactly what, yeah.
- Like that? Yeah.
- Good look.
- So this is good, yeah.
This is good for droplets,
'cause it'll block it.
The only trouble is if you
have any degree of aerosol,
what's happens, is that all of this,
see, it can go right in like that.
That's the problem, you see?
So these are good for droplets,
but you have to be careful
if there's a degree
of aerosolization.
- So if you wear a face shield, Sal,
you should also still wear a mask,
I guess that's what he's suggesting.
But for younger children, especially,
it would be helpful to
see the teachers face.
If face shields aren't very protective
in a classroom setting, and
everyone has to wear a mask,
which they clearly do,
what impact is all this
going to have on the
critical issue of learning?
- It's going to have a huge impact.
Just from the school closures
that have already occurred,
over the spring, a lot
of researchers think
it's going to be as much
as a year of learning loss.
'Cause not only were kids not learning,
they were also forgetting,
they were atrophying.
And basically the
conversation with Dr. Fauci,
even if one of either the
Moderna, or one of the vaccines
become successful, and we're
able to start deploying
them in January, you're
still not going to get
to herd immunity, get them all deployed,
until several months later.
It's a major public
health issue to be able
to get hundreds of
millions of vaccines out.
And so this is going to
be this entire school year
in some form of socially-distanced
or hybrid learning.
And so it's going to be a
really, really tough year.
And the biggest fear is it's
going to drive more inequity.
All of our children, my children, I think,
are just going to be fine,
but there's a lot of kids
who don't have the supports,
who don't have the access,
and they're also going
to be going to schools
that might not have the resources
to be able to provide them adequately.
So it's going to be a tough year.